was passiert wenn wir 100 stunden lang
wach bleiben wie gefährlich ist
schlafmangel und warum schlafen wir
überhaupt die antworten gibt es heute
mit hilfe eines guten kollegen das ist
marcel landers der hier vom kanal tektas
tisch und bekannt für experimente jeder
art darunter auch selbst experimente zu
schlafentzug beim selbst experte man
fahre ich die letzten sieben tage jetzt
nur viereinhalb stunden jeweils
geschlafen wenn ihr sehen wollt wie sich
youtuber selbst zerstören dann seid ihr
hier genau richtig heute bleibe ich 60
stunden woche und habe dadurch noch mehr
halluzinationen und vor allem noch
mehrere und wehrtechnik kennt weiß das
ist nur eine frage der zeit war
das ist dann auch mal irgendwann den 100
stunden schlafentzug durchziehen werde
also freunde der sonne wenn ihr bereit
seid selbst euch wer im schichtdienst
arbeitet gerade ein kleines baby hat
oder gerne mal eine nacht durch feiert
derweil schlafmangel ist grausam
warum sich die sich das freiwillig antut
ist eine geschichte die hier erzählt
werden soll
kurze antwort weil er verrückt ist aber
warum müssen wir eigentlich schlafen
warum müssen wir uns in diesem seltsamen
zustand begeben wo wir bewusst groß
herum liegen und uns völlig angreifbar
machen warum reicht es nicht dass wir
uns einfach nur ausruhen ohne gleich
bewusstlos zu werden die antwort ist
ziemlich interessant aber vor müssen wir
erst mal verstehen was ist schlaf
eigentlich von außen ist es gar nicht so
leicht zu unterscheiden ob jemand
wirklich lebt oder nur so toth und außen
kann es sogar schwer sein zu
unterscheiden ob jemand noch wirklich
wahr ist oder eigentlich schon schläft
misst man jetzt aber die gehirnwellen
einer person dann kann man es ziemlich
genau sagen denn genauso ist schlaf
definiert nämlich über unser gehirn
eigentlich hier hin entstehen zu jeder
zeit elektrische felder die sich mit
unserer hirnaktivität fortlaufend ändern
und diese schwankungen kann man messen
mit hilfe von eeg kurz für
elektroenzephalografie bei einer eeg
messung kriegt man so eine haube voller
elektroden auf dem kopf tut weh
komisch aus also wenn man schließt so
eine elektrode dann hat man bewegt sich
dieser zeit ziemlich schnell ziemlich
viel im kopf passiert es ist übrigens
lars doktor lars dietrich genau genommen
ist schlaf forscher und redet gern über
seine forschung deshalb habe ich ihn
gestoppt damit er uns unter anderem was
zu erzählen gehabt wenn die leute
einschlafen wird wird der ausschlag viel
größer und regelmäßiger und das ist
vielleicht erstmal sich intuitiv weil
man denkt ja auch schlag ist größer das
heißt dass es geht und sagt lila oder
was
und dass man dann später aus monate ist
was passiert ist dass mehr hirnzellen
gleichzeitig das gleiche machen und
deswegen wird auch schlag größer ich bin
so viel passiert das macht nicht mehr
hier sein crm und sein sie machen einen
gemeinsamen band oasis gemeinsame war
bahnhofsklo wales lieb ist der tiefe
schlaf schlafen heißt also ruhe für das
gehirn aber nicht nur das große große
überraschung war dann dass wenn die
leute richtig tief in das plötzlich das
eeg aussieht als wären die war das ist
der mensch steht für rapid eye movement
unschwer zu erkennen an rapid eye
movement dass die phase in der man
träumt und typischerweise auch die phase
in der man mal kurz aufwacht sich um
trägt die decke zu recht sieht und so
weiter und das war so der große
durchbruch schlaf ist nicht einfach
abschalten des gehirns sondern passiert
sehr viel und unter anderem auch etwas
war so viel aktivität offensichtlich im
gehirn verursacht wieder normal
nachzustellen schlaf ist ein unglaublich
spannendes forschungsthema denn vieles
ist immer noch nicht bekannt oder wie
lass es mit erfurt ausdrückt wir wissen
viel zu schlecht was das hier ist wir
wissen nicht wie das hier funktioniert
wir wissen nicht was der hier misst wir
aber die symptome von schlafentzug die
sind wohl bekannt
was passiert bei schlafentzug
als ich las von marcels 100 stunden war
experiment erzähle gibt da folgen der
prognosen hat also ich würde denken dass
der ziemlich oft da saß und jetzt lebe
geguckt hat dann gibt es passieren
leuten die so was machen wir haben dann
berichte dass sie angefangen optische
illusion zu haben
die lust aufs essen verändert sich also
auch wenn man nur eine nacht schlecht
geschlafen hat hat man mehr bock auf
süßes fertige sachen was auch schon
anfängt wenn man noch ein bisschen
schlaf fehlt ist dass man ist die laune
sehr stark leute in einer studie sollten
versuchsteilnehmer die attraktivität von
ausgeschlafenen und unausgeschlafenen
personen bewährten natürlich kam die
ausgeschlafenen deutlich besser weg ich
würde ganz gerne
foto von ihm sehen am nächsten tag
natürlich gehen dinge wie aufmerksamkeit
oder reaktionszeit den bach runter in
der forschung gibt es ein experiment
namens zeigt roger wittmann im prinzip
einfach mal von einem bildschirm sitzt
und in unvorhersagbar abständen kommen
ein signal zum achten punkt und da
musste auch ein knopf drücken es den
punkt gesehen hast diese art von
aufmerksamkeit gegen bei schlafmangel
zunehmend schlechter wenn man nicht
ausgefüllt ist in diesem test macht
fängt es damit an dass man einfach
länger braucht bis man braucht ja das ja
ein punkt ist man geduld hat und dann
hat man hat man halt die leute sitzen
und auf den punkt warten und finger bank
noch fahrt kommt der punkt man geht er
wieder weg und sie haben mich gedrückt
doch an bord nachdem punkt ist sie
merken gar nicht dass sie verpasst haben
dass er das der punkt gekommen ist wenn
dieser punkt jetzt ein rad verreist und
du gerade übermüdet im auto sitzt dann
ist das natürlich gar nicht gut
schlafmangel wird sogar nachweislich
ähnlich wie alkoholkonsum was zum
beispiel die reaktionszeit beträgt das
heißt schlafentzugs experiment
wir sind schon allein deswegen
gefährlich weil man sich und andere im
alltag verletzen könnte der schlafmangel
gilt außerdem die persönliche
wahrnehmung kann trügen stellt euch vor
ihr nehmt eine gruppe von menschen die
normalerweise acht stunden geschlafen
jetzt lass dir diese menschen für eine
studie zwei wochen lagen nur sechs
stunden pro tag schlafen und untersucht
verschiedene sachen erstens der
subjektive wahrnehmung wie fühlst du
dich hast du in den kopf dass nur solche
sollen und zwar ins könnt ihr objektive
dinge messen wie zum beispiel
reaktionszeit und das kommt dabei raus
[Musik]
zwei wochen sind strafen zeichnen ist
eine kunst für sich jedenfalls wenn ich
jetzt kontinuierlich schlafmangel
erleide fühle ich mich die ersten drei
tage immer wieder als noch den tag davor
und irgendwann kommt so ein bereich mich
dahinter haben puls geht es mir ziemlich
scheiße aber ich bin auf dem gleichen
auf dem gleichen level aber wenn man
sich dinge angeschaut wie reaktionszeit
dann sieht das so und jeden tag den ich
wieder zu mir geschlafen wird immer
schlechter
das gibt mir weiter sprich während du
glaubst dass sich dein körper an den
schlafmangel gewöhnt ist die realität
dass dein körper einfach nur
kontinuierlich ab kackt wie sie ist
capital frauen im wasser ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob ich 100 stunden wach bleiben
könnte aber die tatsache dass jemand wie
masse das durchaus schaffen kann scheint
darauf hinzudeuten dass schlaf jetzt gar
nicht mal so überlebenswichtig sein kann
deshalb jetzt noch mal die frage von
vorhin warum schlafen wie überhaupt
jetzt wird's wissenschaftlich ist es
höchstwahrscheinlich so dass es mehrere
funktion von schlaf gibt schlaf spielt
für das gehirn zum beispiel eine
wichtige rolle beim regenerieren und
beim lernen ist ist eigentlich schon so
ein bisschen was dran wenn man sagt dass
man über irgendwas man die nacht
schlafen muss jede körperzelle ist wie
ein wunderwerk mit lauter mechanismen
die ineinandergreifen und im schlaf
finden lauter instandhaltungsprozesse
statt da wird zwischen den zahnrädern
geputzte wird gilt da werden schrauben
nachgezogen und ich klar forschung
hätten auch etwas interessantes das
gehirn braucht schlaf um sich zu
entmüllen also leben bedeutet viele
chemische reaktionen sprich stoffwechsel
manche stoffwechselprodukte brauchen wir
andere fallen als müll an dieser müll
wird über eine art leitungssystem
entsorgt über das so genannte
lymphatische system der körper hat also
eine art müll entsorgungssystem und das
verrückte soll das gehirn so was nicht
hat das gehirn bzw das ganze zentrale
nervensystem ist nicht an dieses
lymphatische entsorgungssystem
angeschlossen doch auch im gehirn
passieren ständig chemische reaktionen
auch dort fällt müller an und wie der
entsorgt wird hat eine dänische
neurowissenschaftlerin 2013 heraus indem
sie farbstoffe einsetzte und verfolgte
wie die sich aus dem gehirn
herausbewegen vereinfacht könnt ihr euch
vorstellen dass der müll des gehirns
durch das gehirngewebe doch in dieses
lymphatische entsorgungssystem hinein
sichern kann
und da die gewebe zellen im gehirn keine
nervenzellen sind gliazellen heißen
nennt man dieses gesamte müll
entsorgungssystem des gehirns
lymphatische system eine vor
zusammensetzung aus klima- und
lymphatische system und jetzt verspannte
diese müllentsorgung passiert im schlaf
etwa viermal so schnell wie im
wachzustand schlaf kümmert sich darum
kann man sich vorstellen wenn man jetzt
jahrelang zu wenig schläft könnte sich
durch die schlechtere müll entsorgen
mit der zeit irgendwas ungewollt ist
eben wie hier in anreichern und so
krankheiten
und lars und versucht genau dass er
untersucht ob schlafmangel zu alzheimer
parkinson oder anderen
neurodegenerativen erkrankungen führen
könnt aber einmalig also für so
verrückte schlaf experimente können
menschen durchaus extrem lange wach oder
im scheinbar ohne bleibende schäden der
hier ist nicht der einzige verrückte
gibt derzeit offizielle rekord für
schwach bleiben wie bei ganzen elf tage
ist das buch der rekorde führt keine
einträge mehr über schlafentzug um
menschen nicht dazu zu motivieren denn
bei einem sind sich experten einig
chronischer schlafentzug ist ungesund
schlafmangel führt zu erhöhtem blutdruck
und ein chronisch erhöhter blutdruck
fördert herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen
schlafmangel wirkt sich auch negativ auf
unsere blutzucker aus und ein chronisch
erhöhter blutzuckerspiegel fördert
diabetes typ 2 warum habe ich dann
marcel nicht von seinem experiment
abgehalten gut als ich von so was nicht
abhalten lässt
stell dir vor jemand würde total fertig
und trinken oder jemand würde sich da
gehört nunmal von zucker ernähren nichts
anderem
den wird es richtig schlecht gehen je
länger das macht desto schlechter dessen
geht wenn dann wieder so verlauf kommt
und a6 trägt dann wird er ein bisschen
erholung brauchen danach wird es ihm
wieder gut gehen aber es kann man aber
nicht schließen dass das alkohol trinken
oder sich nur von zuckern er keinen
keinen schaden verursachen würden das
sieht man eben wenn man solche leute
anguckt die über jahre oder jahrzehnte
viel trinken oder sich sehr schlecht
ernähren da sieht man dass das den sehr
starken gesundheitlichen effekt hat und
so sollte man sich meiner meinung nach
auch schlaf vorstellen wir sollten uns
schlafen stehen übrigens wenn das jetzt
wissenschaftlich untersuchen wollte wie
sich 100 stunden schlafentzug auf den
menschen auswirken könnte das schwierig
werden denn lars vermutet dass er eine
solche studie heutzutage an keiner
ethikkommission für bei kriegen würde
wissenschaftlich gesehen ist technisches
experiment zwar nicht statistisch
signifikant aber dafür eine umso
wertvollere fallstudien wenn er also
sehen wollt wie es ihm ergangen ist
schaue ich noch meinen
dazu an denn da verrate ich auch mit
welchen mitteln man das überhaupt
schaffen kann
zwei tropfen bereichen verlinkt ich euch
überall gehen das war hier ja nur die
theorie die praxis in voller länge und
mit allen halluzinationen und einem
punkt dran gibt es dann bei dichters
tisch für mich nämlich mit aus diesem
video das schlaf- und schlafforschung
unglaublich spannend ist so dass ich
früher oder später noch ein video dazu
machen muss weil wir hier jetzt nur so
ein paar basics anreisen konnten
das heißt wenn ich irgendwas zum thema
schlaf besonders interessiert schreibt
in die kommentare dann kann ich das beim
nächsten video aufgreifen und wir sehen
uns in der endphase der sich auch bei
ihr ist der bremer twitter bin
das könnte interessant sein für alle
freunde der sonne
die gerne wissen wollen was diese mine
for you to noch so macht und hier kommt
die haut zum video von plastischer damit
rein und in dallas den barcelona tests
ist groß
am donnerstag ist ein leipzig